I can walk into the White House right
now I can go sleep it I can go sleep in
the president sheets if I'm invisible
and do it every day when he's out
playing basketball all the secrets of
the world are yours information
free-flowing guys that's my knowledge of
getting why you know did you just have a
mental breakdown yeah I did look we all
want superpowers and obviously the best
to our flight or invisibility imagine
the miracle of flight soaring through
the clouds the wind through your hair or
you could be some creepy little
invisible perv sneaking into a locker
room I might be kind of biased on this
one but if you're interested the pervs
will try and keep it a fair fight flight
versus invisibility it's debatable
flying is for children I'm for flight
I'm very much Pro invisibility today I'm
arguing for flight I'm Pro flight
because duh Pro invisibility team flight
I'm for invisibility ah you thought I
was invisible for a second flying is net
has been man's dream since the moment
extreme woman is named does it matter
oh yeah I like you and we're just
talking we're gonna go to coffee you
just fly away I'm never talking to you
again cuz you're a freak
travel cheap easy tons of holes in that
argument but oh my god no traffic jams
good night I would you could go anywhere
so fast you ever been to New York City
Zack I have how long did it take for you
to get to New York City six hours six
hours and that's just in the plane yeah
check with the TSA that is not time sure
there's you're not carrying cargo you
know how much tickets cost for the
Superbowl imagine being able to just
hover right above the field may be
pretty cool imagine getting sniped by
the US military when you're doing that
where you're interrupting the show
that's my other problem with flying
around a little flashy don't you think
oh look at me Oh
leaving your stomach exposed to everyone
down below they could just shoot you in
the [ __ ] or the boobs in your hips what
kind of an argument is this imagine me
just putting on a space helmet or a
scuba tank
who's got fly to space I want to see
what space is like it's not that great
I've seen the Martian I could be studied
at some point either the guy could be
studied it's going to be a test
experiment you don't want to be I'm an
organ donor there's a fun prank that you
could do by flying to you you just make
a really really big bird costume and
then you're the Loch Ness monster of
this guy can you dress like a dragon to
make people think you're a dragon in the
sky no you can
not because you're invisible that's the
prank the frake is on you you're donning
a party city costume and flying over the
oh it would not be a party city costume
I would get a majority of it from jo-ann
fabrics if a bird poops falls are you
gonna be pooping on people Gary no I got
people and you're on top of a building
and you see people like walking by are
you just like you know what I think I
want to poop on like a bird if there was
a getaway plan maybe think of the movies
you could sneak into well you can sneak
into it no there may be you want to be
half flying above the Superbowl how
about being on the field on the action
you're gonna get knocked over
oh you don't gotta go step in the
nosebleeds either you can get right in
the stage I could be backstage with
Beyonce I could be Beyonce's friend and
she wouldn't even know is this creepy
yes how about being in the locker room
hearing what the coach is telling Peyton
Manning this is perfect cuz you're
already talking about sneaking into
locker rooms bingo you little creep you
just want to see boobs you got me I
wanna I want to see naked people
unfortunately for you I'm not a perv so
I wouldn't use it for that I think
you're unfortunate perfect I'm living in
a world where people use invisibility
for good I'm not living in this you know
click and fly in the wall [ __ ]
I would rather do cool things like walk
into a bank just feel money not even
take it just feel money have you ever
done that you just want to be a ghost no
because I want to be alive and have a
soul still in a family one day you can
break into banks and take money and give
it to the poor no one's gonna know just
straight up a link now I'm kind of yes
pass that Peter Pan was committing
crimes by trespassing into those rich
people's place steal from the rich give
to the needy all money is digital now
anyways how is that you also have
computer hacking skills I do when I
stand behind I'm like oh is passwords
password really mr. president I could be
at the office and if I want to here
without my boss is saying or something
like that I mean of course I have to
strip down naked but I mean there's some
things have to do before anything's you
put batteries in remote right you can
get your game your all you go sir I want
all moment no but no guys don't help up
people by stealing from these top secret
things
watch me flies I mean invisible people
still leave footprints now wear shoes
that look like bear tracks could you
imagine if you saw just an invisible
bear tracks
could you imagine a bear that's
invisible that's literally now these
dear
if there's an ultimate killing machine
Wow when are you getting off-track [ __ ]
bears
any superpower to have no matter what
we're going to be rich right oh we're
making money we're gonna be we're making
back in visibility's obviously disappear
your superpower here it's more practical
invisibility and flight together would
be the ultimate superpower and I don't
know why that wasn't an option flying is
beautiful
flying is elegant wine is right it's
clear that invisibility is the way to go
just fly and because we've always wanted
to what else I mean uh you tell us in
the comments what do you like
invisibility or like get that boy really
go I'm going in between their legs I'm
like over here tad norm of the shoulder
that's what invisibility does flying
it's just like hey I'm gonna go be by
myself and fly around you'd be a great
pizza delivery boy